bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce 20 avril l'armée sert de ferment
la frontière entre le monténégro et la
croatie isolant un peu plus le pouvoir
indépendant monténégrins les réfugiés
kosovars du monténégro sont menacés nous
le verrons avec maryse burgot en direct
depuis podgorica et nous serons
également en albanie avec notre envoyé
spécial anne consigny en macédoine avec
valérie fournioux où les témoignages des
kosovars sont toujours aussi dramatique
mais les stratégies de l'otan à la
veille de la cinquième semaine de
conflit sont en échec
l'approvisionnement en pétrole de la
serbie continue en france la solidarité
à l'égard des réfugiés est toujours très
forte dans l'actualité également une
journée pas ordinaire pour les hommes
politiques à droite finalement l'udf ne
devrait pas faire listes communes aux
européennes avec le rpr entre football
et violence les compétitions vont
reprendre quand même en scène s'animer
avec une protection policière plus
importante 7 aux frontières de la serbie
que les événements semblent se
précipiter ce soir plusieurs centaines
de soldats de l'armée yougoslave sont
entrés dans une zone démilitarisée à
l'extrême sud de la croatie tandis qu
d'autres unités procédait à la fermeture
de la frontière entre le monténégro et
la croatie
il faut toujours rappeler que le
monténégro fait partie de la fédération
yougoslave mais que son gouvernement
installé à podgorica la capitale tente
de maintenir une ligne indépendante et
critique à l'égard de slobodan milosevic
mais albanais du kosovo qui sont venus
se réfugier au monténégro ne sont pas
quitte pour autant de leur peur car les
militaires serbes sont toujours là et
ils procéderaient même à des séparations
de famille
reportage maryse burgot et gilles
jacquet ils ont trouvé refuge dans les
camps de déplacés du nord du monténégro
ils ont encore la peur au ventre nous
sommes dans la ville de rhodes jahier la
frontière avec le kosovo est à moins de
6 kilomètres
mais les militaires et paramilitaires
serbes sont eux aussi très proche
embusqué dans la montagne ou dans des
camps fraîchement installé à l'intérieur
même du monténégro les hommes de laroin
viennent d'en bas et aussi d'en haut ils
les enlèvent les emmène et les fera les
bras
selon l'otan il se réfère au convoyage
de ces réfugiés
un nettoyage ethnique auraient ainsi
commencé à l'intérieur de la république
du monténégro
ce groupe de femmes de la même famille
nous expliquent qu'elles ont été séparés
de force de leurs hommes alors qu'elles
n'étaient plus au kosovo
leurs agresseurs étaient des militaires
serbes une fille de 16 ans il lui en lui
son pull sur la tête ils l'ont allongé
par terre il annonce qu à pic de dante
et puis longtemps élevé avec tous les
autres la police et les militaires
monténégrins fidèles au président
réformateur djukanovic ont donc reçu
l'ordre de vérifier tous les passages
entre le kosovo et le monténégro ses
hommes savent déjà que la aux trois
villages albanophone du monténégro ont
été vidées de leur population
la situation est à ce point tendue que
médecins du monde médecins sans
frontières réduisent aujourd'hui de
moitié leur personnel dans les camps du
nord
ils sont terrorisés et énergie sont
terrorisés par la présence même de ses
forces militaires qui les ont fait fuir
de chez eux menacés oui nous pouvons
l'être nous si on est trop nombreux
aussi par la présence trop nombreux on
les provoque dans le nord du monténégro
la population est à majorité musulmane
ces hommes et ces femmes commencent donc
eux aussi à fuir vers le sud
nous avons rencontré cet après midi
quelques députés du parti monténégrins
si des la slovène danilo des vitres
selon lui les informations sur un début
de nettoyage ethnique dans le nord ne
sont que probable il ne faut pas qu'ils
ont peur qu'ils ont peur mais ce sont
eux qui font un petit peu aussi de la
propagande
il y à des groupes qui fut par exemple
je ne sais pas à sarajevo wire donc nous
ne savons pas pourquoi ils font cela ils
sont les citoyens de l'énigme chéri ils
doivent rester avec nous et défendre
notre pays comment ses fidèles du leader
serbe de belgrade
lise ce soir que l'armée de slobodan
milosevic prendra position au monténégro
partout quand cela lui semblera
nécessaire par l'usure go vous êtes en
direct de podgorica la capitale du
monténégro avait vous confirmation de
cette fermeture des frontières opéré par
l'armée serbe
écoutez en fait la situation est assez
confuse à ce sujet c'est vrai que cet
après midi le gouvernement monténégrins
a officiellement annoncé que ce poste
frontière entre la croatie et le
monténégro et est désormais tenu par les
militaires serbes fidèles à slobodan
milosevic mais en fait il semble que la
situation soit plus compliqué puisque ce
soir ici on nous annonce que ce poste
frontière est finalement toujours entre
les mains de la police monténégrine
fidèles à monsieur djukanovic
en fait c'est une situation assez
compliquée c'est auront ce livre là un
véritable bras de fer entre les uns et
les autres
un bras de fer entre ceux qui veulent
garder ce poste frontière et ceux qui
voudraient leur prendre ce qui est très
clair c'est que cet endroit est
stratégique
vous savez que c'est la seule
possibilité pour les journalistes pour
la presse étrangère de rentrer au
monténégro est donc en yougoslavie
le seul moyen de rentrer et djukanovic
veut absolument que la presse étrangère
reste ici au monténégro vous savez que
des rumeurs de coup d'état contre lui
circule depuis maintenant trois semaines
et la presse tu es le seul moyen pour
lui d'informer le monde de ce qui peut
arriver ici
alors revenons sur ces rumeurs car ce
n'est pas la première fois que le
gouvernement du monténégro est ainsi
menacée est ce que certains ont déjà
préparé une sorte de fuite vers
l'étranger
nous avons en fait interviewer qu'il ya
quelques jours un porte parole du
gouvernement qui nous a dit cet après
midi qu'il partait qu'il prenait la
suite il nous a dit ça au téléphone
c'est la seule personne qui nous ait dit
ça pour l'instant
ce que je peux vous dire de manière
certaine c'est qu'il ya en ce moment une
réunion très importante qui se tient
entre le président milo djukanovic et
entre le commandant de la 2e armée
fédérale fidèles à slobodan milosevic
je ne sais pas de quoi on y parle on y
parle forcément de ce problème de poste
frontière on y parle évidemment de ce
début de nettoyage ethnique dans le nord
du monténégro et on parle aussi du
problème de la mobilisation des hommes
vous savez que la plupart des
monténégrins en tout cas un certain
nombre de monténégrins refuse d'aller
combattre dans l'armée de slobodan
milosevic c'est tout ce que nous savons
pour l'instant nous ne cette réunion
n'est pas terminée elle est toujours en
cours précision maryse vous pouvez
travailler relativement librement ou
êtes un peu sous contrôle serbe
nous sommes arrêtés par les fédéraux
assez régulièrement papattes pas si
souvent que ça en fait nous avons eu un
problème une fois parce que nous avions
filmé des choses qui ne leur avait pas
plus mais ces derniers jours je peux pas
dire que nous soyons
contrôle et nous faisons ce que nous
voulons ce que nous nous faisons
attention de ne surtout pas filmer des
fédéraux de ne surtout pas s'il met des
sites militaires on est ici en état de
guerre et évidemment il faut prendre
garde à ne pas filmer ce genre de chose
sinon évidemment on nous expulserait
merci maryse en albanie à couquèques le
haut commissariat de l'onu veut à tout
prix accélérer l'évacuation des réfugiés
car la situation dans les camps tient
toujours de la survie dans des
conditions extrêmement précaires
reportage and ponsinet philippe jasselin
lorsque la bâche du camion se soulève
ils sont des milliers à londres le cou
pour voir ce qu'il convient au début
cela qu elle est la police décide
d'organiser deux rangées la file
d'attende commence une file qu'il faut
constamment ricoh france en entamant
l'autre heureusement aujourd'hui
contrairement aux jours précédents
il ne pleut pas
à l'intérieur pain et sardines pour
commencer la distribution se fait au
jugé difficile d'établir la ration je
donne c'est tout je donne tout ce que je
sais c'est que dans ce camp il ya des
gens qui ont faim c'est un camp qui
n'est pas organisé ce sont vos nouveaux
réfugiés
on est obligé de distribuer avec la
police serait trop dangereux
cette organisation allemande travaille
ici depuis trois semaines elle a déjà
acheminé trois gros camions de 24 tonnes
chacun ce sont des chiffres qui
consommeront pas ce pouvoir soit on est
tellement personnes dans laquelle elle
ça fait trois heures que j'attends ici
je dors dans la voiture avec mes trois
enfants la nuit car il sert à rien à y
faire la khl maintenant quand on arrive
rails du rap lors de fêtes tout le monde
n'a pas été servi cette fois mais il ya
eu d'autres distributions sexy halle
d'attentes étaient celles du corps local
aux lampions sur la place de couteau
concise est vous êtes en direct avec
nous de cooker est ce que vous allez
précisions sur l'état des frontières
sont elles fermées ce qui lie à d'autres
réfugiés de côté
peut-on savoir combien vient écouter
apparemment la frontière n'est pas
techniquement fermé puisque une dizaine
de quelques dizaines de personnes sont
passées par la voie officielle depuis
dimanche après midi
cela dit il doit bien y avoir une raison
pour que dix mille personnes soit passé
samedi et que depuis dimanche il n'y en
ait plus que quelques dizaines
alors c'est peut-être le nettoyage
ethnique qui ne se produit plus
exactement au même rythme peut-être y
at-il une pause temporaire au moins il
est à peu près certain qu'il ya en tout
cas une gestion du flux de réfugiés par
les serbes qui peut être via des points
de contrôle établi à 5,10 qu'il aurait
de la frontière puisqu'on sait que les
serbes sont très très présent le long
des routes et il est déjà arrivé que des
réfugiés soient réorientés sur des
chemins plus compliquée que ce qu'il
voulait faire ce qu'ils voulaient
prendre est également certains ont dû
rebrousser chemin mais sur tous ces
points on en est réduit aux hypothèses
alors mais les personnes que vous
montrez dans le reportage nous non
diffusés qui viennent chercher du pain
sont très nombreuses et ce qu'il est
envisagé de les évacuer plus vert vers
le sud du pays où est ce qu'elles vont
rester longtemps dans ce camp et que les
jours sont en permanence évacuées dans
le sud du pays encore avant-hier il y
avait une camionnette qui circulait dans
les rues le matin tôt parce que la route
est longue pour tirana pour inviter les
gens à monter dans les camions et les
bus en direction du sud du pays
cela dit il reste quand même une
centaine de milliers de personnes à coke
s et ça c'est déjà très lourd le hcr dit
que ces gens reçoivent aujourd'hui à
l'heure actuelle à peu près 650 grammes
de rations alimentaires par jour mais
quarante deux mille d'entre eux
aujourd'hui sont logés dans des familles
albanaises et c'est une situation
d'urgence ils sont parfois des dizaines
par chambre et on se demande comment
cette situation va pouvoir durer comment
les relations entre les albanais les
kosovars vont évoluer cette situation
doit durer plus longtemps
merci m quant à l'aide humanitaire
internationale qui afflue en albanie il
semblerait qu'une mafia albanaise
organise des détournements vers des
réseaux d'économie parallèle la
macédoine a ouvert un nouveau camp de
réfugiés tout en appelant les pays de
l'union européenne à accueillir plus de
se voir qu'ils ne l'ont fait jusqu'à
présent au camp de braga où se trouve
actuellement 26 mille personnes il est
très difficile d'établir les identités
respectives aussi bien l'office
international des migrations que les
experts de l'organisation pour la
sécurité et la coopération en europe
csce tente cependant de mettre en place
une sorte de fichier il faut se souvenir
que les serbes ont souvent détruit tous
les papiers d'identité des réfugiés
reportage à brax jda valérie fonio
frédéric basket se relaient 24 heures
sur 24 pour le personnel de l'office
international des migrations
la tâche est immense il enregistre tous
les noms des réfugiés du kosovo qui
entrent dans ce camp lors base de
travail ces documents à en-tête du hcr
rempli même si les papiers d'identité
sont des faux papiers ils sont demandés
de l'enregistrement
voir s'ils ont dévalé s'ils en ont pas
et si son nom pour le numéro on signera
pas seule certitude c'est à partir de
ces listes ainsi constitué que l'on
essaie on retrouve difficilement dans le
camp les candidats au départ pour un
pays de l'alliance
là il s'agit du vol pour la belgique ils
sont partis pour une autre destination
rien n'est véritablement centralisée ici
et il arrive souvent qu'un même individu
et plusieurs fiches à son nom mais peu
importe quand il s'agit d'une bonne
nouvelle dans ce poncif
en tout cas on ne remplace pas ses
papiers puisque lorsque ils sont
embarqués dans les avions
le pays demandeur ne demande aucun
papier il démontre simplement que
d'avoir le petit cadeau alors que van
avalisée par lionel cher et c'est la
seule pièce légal avec les gars les
passagers partis dans les pays étrangers
pourtant le hr a obligation de remettre
un document à chaque personne sans
identité lui assurant ainsi le statut de
réfugié en ce moment ils n'en n'ont pas
besoin quand ce sera le cas on le
donnera mais dans le camp ce n'est qu'un
bout de papier c'est inutile mais c'est
aussi une protection pour eux ils sont
protégés dans ce camp
ce n'est pas un camp ou vers un camp
12les difficile de sortir si ce n'est
pour un pays de l'alliance
une garantie peut-être pour les
autorités macédoniennes car un document
officiel du hr permettrait aux réfugiés
de sortir du camp est donc de rester en
macédoine
parmi les moyens de rétorsion contre le
régime de slobodan milosevic est
envisagée par les pays membres de l'otan
il ya la possibilité d'un embargo
pétrolier mais l'union européenne n'a
pas réussi à se mettre d'accord sur une
interdiction des ventes des
approvisionnements en produits
pétroliers à la yougoslavie le ministre
français hubert védrine souhaite pour un
tel objectif une base juridique solide
explique était ce matin dans un
entretien publié par le figaro pas de
blocus donc sans un accord de l'onu
d'autant que son application ne serait
pas très évidente explications pascal
golomer avec agnès monteuil jean-paul
chaussée
la raffinerie de pancevo en flammes pour
les avions de l'otan aucun doute la
cible est stratégique
voilà pourquoi ils n'ont bombardé à
plusieurs reprises depuis le début du
conflit
l'autre raffinerie du pays à novi sad a
suivi le même sort
le but privé l'armée serbe de carburant
au plus vite
selon l'otan ces raffineries sont hors
service mais les alliés se préoccupent
désormais de l'approvisionnement en
pétrole
ce pétrole qui arrive par bateau dans le
port croate de rijeka avant d'être
acheminés par oléoducs par la serbie un
deuxième oléoduc permet d'importer du
pétrole de russie via la hongrie
cet approvisionnement serait aujourd'hui
interrompue reste une troisième
possibilité le port de bar au monténégro
où les pétroliers continue d'accoster
autant de solutions d'approvisionnement
pour la serbie qu'il s'agit selon le
secrétaire d'état américaine madeleine
albright d'éliminer grâce à l'embargo
la question fait débat parmi les
européens
hubert védrine ministre français on a
discuté aujourd'hui avec ses partenaires
des bases légales incontestable donc
nous continuons à travailler cette base
légale n'existe pas encore en effet le
conseil de sécurité de l'onu n'a voté
deux résolutions que pour un embargo sur
les armes et la russie s'opposerait à
tout embargo sur le pétrole
l'union européenne tente donc de trouver
sa propre solution tout en sachant que
les serbes dispose peut-être un stock de
carburant encore confortable
on a détruit à peu près 70 % des lieux
de stockage mais il ya certainement les
lieux pour les militaires cachés un peu
partout dans la serbie est ailleurs et
on n'a pas une idée ce qu'ont bien
quelle est la situation pour ces lieux
cachés peut-être enfin le carburant et
il discrètement apportées par camions en
provenance de roumanie ou de bulgarie
par exemple un trafic impossible à
évaluer
impossible surtout pour l'otan à
interrompre totalement à la veille de
vrais une cinquième semaine d'action
militaire l'otan procèdent un
renforcement en hommes et en matériel de
son dispositif bien sûr l'idée d'une
action terrestre est toujours écarté
mais ses forces nouvelles ne sont pas
destinés à l'action arm
quant à françois corner pour sa 27ème
nuit de raids
l'otan a pris une nouvelle fois pour
cible en serbie centrale d'une ville de
garnison qui abrite le quartier général
de la troisième armée serbe opérant au
kosovo niche qui est également la
troisième ville de serbie aurait essuyé
les tirs d'une dizaine de missiles
ce complexe industriel de valjevo à 80
km au sud de belgrade a lui aussi été
bombardés d'après l'otan ses usines
dévasté fabrique est également de
l'armement
quelques heures après ces nouvelles
frappes aériennes
le patriarche de toutes les russies
alexis ii célébrée dans la plus grande
église orthodoxe de belgrade une messe
pour la paix devant plus de dix mille
fidèles le patriarche a accusé l'otan de
vouloir imposer en yougoslavie je cite
un ordre fondé sur le diktat de la force
brutale
alexis ii a été reçu par slobodan
milosevic et sa femme mira markovic
apparus ensemble pour la première fois
devant les caméras depuis le début du
conflit
au cours de cet entretien au palais
présidentiel le président yougoslave a
déclaré que la russie et l'église
orthodoxe russe pouvait jouer un rôle
essentiel dans l'arrêt des raids de
l'otan
pendant ce temps les renforts américains
continuaient à débarquer sur l'aéroport
de tirana en albanie mais il n'est
toujours pas question selon l'otan
d'offensive terrestre
ces soldats français eux déployés en
macédoine avant la crise participaient à
la force d'extraction des observateurs
au kosovo avant les frappes
aujourd'hui ils patrouillent le long de
la frontière avec le kosovo pour la
sécuriser de là ils peuvent observer les
mouvements des forces serbes pouvons
voir les serbes dit ce chef de section
sommet des montagnes et en parle dans la
valeur de l'autre côté de la frontière
le commandant de la troisième armée
yougoslave lui attend toujours dit il la
remet aux pieds les soldats de l'otan
on en parlait depuis plusieurs jours
sans les voir les hélicoptères
américains apache sont arrivés cet
après-midi en albanie seront
opérationnels que d'ici une semaine
après avoir été déployés dans le nord du
territoire albanais commenté bernard
lebrun annoncé depuis plusieurs jours à
grand renfort de communiqués du
pentagone l'arrivée des hélicoptères
apache aura finalement été très discrète
sans doute pour ne pas provoquer les
forces serbes ou gêner l'albanie qui
lentement mais sûrement se transforme en
véritable porte avion des forces de
l'otan ce nouvel armement offensif
rappelle washington n'est pas l'élément
précurseur d'une offensive terrestre
il est présenté comme le complément
nécessaire à une offensive aérienne qui
a montré ses limites contre l'infanterie
c'est que ni les bombardiers ni les
avions de chasse ne semble avoir
gravement endommagé 900 millions de
francs l'unité fabriqué en arizona par
boeing et mcdonnell douglas le h60 4 un
équipage réduit un pilote un tireur ce
qui en fait un redoutable appareil
d'attac antichars c'est son canon
rotatif de 30 mm montés dans laxe du
fuselage et tirant 625 ou à la minute
de part et d'autre de ces ailerons s'y
ajoutent deux lance-roquettes de 70 mm
ainsi que des lanceurs de missiles
antichars doté d'un moteur puissant et
silencieux la page peut sans busqué de
longues minutes derrière un obstacle
naturel et surgir par surprise pour
attaquer sa cible largement utilisée par
les américains durant la guerre du golfe
l'hélicoptère a démontré son efficacité
en détruisant des centaines de chars ou
autres véhicules blindés pour autant
l'appareil a aussi ses faiblesses il
vole nécessairement à basse altitude et
relativement lentement environ 280 km
heure ce qui en fait une cible de choix
pour n'importe quel fantassins équipé
d'un lance roquettes
d'où les délais et cet énorme logistique
nécessaire à leur déploiement
d'abord en sommes ces parachutistes
arrivés hier à tirana ont pour mission
de protéger et entretenir les
hélicoptères au sol pas moins de deux
mille six cents hommes pour 24 appareils
ensuite on arme d'appui ses chars
lance-roquettes multiples ont pris
péniblement il ya deux jours les routes
et pistes d'albanie pour gagner la
frontière nord il faudra là encore
attendre leur mise en place pour que les
hélicoptères les y rejoindre
et puis surtout les pilotes d'apache
auront besoin d'un formateur pour
localiser l'artillerie serbes au kosovo
deux solutions utiliser les
renseignements transmis par les forces
de l'ue ces cas où infiltrés au sol des
forces spéciales comme ces groupements
commando de parachutistes français
stationnés en macédoine que l'on voit
ici à l'entraînement il y a deux
semaines la télévision sert nous montrer
ces images des chars de l'armée fédérale
parcourant les routes du kosovo mais il
ya longtemps qu'il ne circule plus ils
sont désormais caché camoufler ou
enterrées il faudra d'abord les
débusquer selon une dépêche de l'agencé
'reuters' et 1t ménages de l'eau et
soeur d'un expert dresseur il ya des
échanges de tirs actuellement la
frontière albanaise entre des forces
serbes et albanaises alors laurent
boussier il ya quatre semaines
l'opération forces alliées de l'otan en
yougoslavie été déclenchée
c'est le moment de faire une sorte de
bilan provisoire est ce que les bus
recherchés sont atteints boudet claude
quand dans la nuit du 24 au 25 mars
dernier les avions de l'otan ont frappé
pour la première fois la yougoslavie le
but des responsables politiques des 19
pays de l'alliance atlantique était de
ramener le président serbe slobodan
milosevic à la table des négociations
d'empêcher les exactions des forces
paramilitaires serbes au kosovo et
d'imposer la présence dans cette
province d'une force de maintien de la
paix tu quatre semaines après il faut
bien le reconnaître
aucun de ses buts de guerre n'a été
atteint le président serbe semble plus
solidement installé au pouvoir que
jamais l'intensification des frappes qui
devait casser l'armée yougoslave
n'empêche pas celle ci d'agir au kosovo
où elle s'est même renforcée ces
derniers jours et les deux tiers des
kosovars d'origine albanaise ont été
chassés de chez eux dans des conditions
de violence inouïe pour l'instant donc
malheureusement on peut parler d'un
échec
l'échec provisoire mais la question de
savoir si cette guerre si ce conflit va
durer mais écoutez ça risque de durer
parce que pour l'instant l'otan ne
semble pas avoir de stratégie de
rechange si ce n'est une sorte d'
escalade militaire plus d'avion plus de
cibles plus de destructions les alliés
pensent peut-être avec juste raison que
ces frappes finiront par affaiblir le
président serbe mais ça risque d'être
long et dans ce contexte où l'impression
de malaise grandit ou l'otan semble
naviguer à vue
l'idée d'une opération terrestre fait
son chemin sans qu'on sache d'ailleurs
vraiment si elle serait limitée au
kosovo où est celle ci elle engloberait
l'ensemble de la serbie pour le temps
ces choix sont cruciaux il y va de la
crédibilité d'une alliance qui dans
quelques jours va perdre a fêté ses 50
ans et qui pour qui ce baptême du feu
pourrait faire perdre sa crédibilité
merci laurent et réponse de slobodan
milosevic qui promet de ne jamais céder
il donne une interview à un journal
serbe à belgrade journal rapporte des
déclarations soldats milosevic selon
lesquelles l'offensive de l'otan a fait
très peu de dégâts selon slobodan
milosevic
cet après midi monsieur jacques chirac
qui monsieur tony blair se sont
entretenus au téléphone on indique à
l'elysée qu'ils sont tous les deux sur
une ligne de grande fermeté en france
monsieur robert hue secrétaire national
du pcf estime que nous sommes dans
l'impasse après 26 jours de
bombardements et monsieur georges sarre
du mouvement des citoyens mouvement
présidé par jean pierre chevènement
évoque un risque d'éclatement politique
encore d'intervention terrestre en
yougoslavie
un sondage évoque la situation au kosovo
pour bébé à paris match 66 % des
français approuvent la participation
française au raid 50% seraient
favorables à une intervention terrestre
impliquant les soldats français
et puis en corollaire les cotes de
popularité de jacques chirac et lionel
jospin sont en hausse de 5 et 8 points
65 et 64 % de bonnes opinions pour le
président et le premier ministre
quant à l'aide humanitaire concrètement
manifesté par les familles françaises
elle est toujours aussi forte nous
allons devoir à caen chantilly et nancy
avec ces nouveaux exemples de solidarité
commentaires caroline d'audrin depuis ce
matin dans le calvados chaque structure
d'accueil susceptibles de recevoir des
réfugiés visiter ici à
saint-aubin-sur-mer la cellule de crise
fait le point dans les centres de
vacances
une trentaine de personnes vont être
accueillis prise en charge avant d'être
installés dans les appartements sociaux
dans un premier temps les réfugiés qui
vont arriver vont être orientées sur une
structure de type hébergements
collectifs pour nous permettre de mieux
les connaître de savoir quels sont leurs
besoins de leur apporter un secours
bilan médical bigeon psychologique
l'accueil des réfugiés c'est une
situation qu'on connaît déjà chez les
hartmann à plusieurs reprises ils ont
reçu en tunisie un malien
cette fois il s'agit d'une maman et de
son fils kosovars gravement blessé avec
l'expérience ils savent combien les
délicats d'accueillir ces réfugiés soir
peut accueillir le plus simplement
possible parce que je pense que les ont
déjà vu beaucoup de monde ça fait deux
joueurs qui sont à un kit avec qui
retrouve un petit peu de paix aussi
parce qu'il n'arrête pas de voir les
albanais s'enfuir en tracteurs les
agriculteurs de la région de nancy se
sentent particulièrement concernés chez
laissions comme celle et parisse on
recense les pièces les domicile
indépendant susceptibles de les
accueillir ils on se pose aussi beaucoup
de questions ne serait-ce que le barrage
de la langue
il faut savoir que ces personnes - est
là il faut gérer bien souvent pas sous
sûrement mon exploitation sur mon
tracteur
s'ils viennent en train de traire une
vache on y pense il va falloir aussi les
atouts peu partout ce même élan de
générosité tout le monde est prêt à
accueillir les 500 nouveaux kosovars
attendus en france jeudi prochain
autre exemple c'est à lyon une vie
presque normale comme ancêtre possible
pour une famille de réfugiés albanais
une équipe de france 2 avec elsa
margouilles didier robert a pu les
accompagner tout au long de cette
journée
deuxième jour en france dans ce centre
d'accueil de lyon les réfugiés
reconstruisent leur vie aujourd'hui ils
ont reçu un peu d'argent des
associations pour subvenir à leurs
besoins
35 francs par jour et par adulte 24
francs par enfant
alors ils ont pu faire quelques courses
et à leur tour inviter leurs amis
albanais à venir boire un café et mines
est arrivé dimanche avec son mari n'a
semé et ses enfants aujourd'hui un ami
qui vit en france depuis dix ans est
venu leur rendre visite
la vie reprend son cours moi je suis
prêt à travailler parce que ici on nous
offre tous les enfants ils iront à
l'école
même les deux femmes pourront apprendre
le français j'aimerais arriver à
travailler rapidement
depuis qu'elle est en france et mines et
appelle tous les soirs en macédoine
sa mère est toujours là bas dans le camp
de skopje elle lui dit qu'elle est bien
installé bon tout le reste de ma famille
est en allemagne mais j'aimerais bien
faire venir ma mère en france
je suis inquiète pour elle hier soir
naze mais sa famille était invitée chez
leurs amis ça tire ils lui ont raconté
comment les militaires serbes dont les
ont chassés de chez eux
le retour au pays paraît bien
hypothétique en fait on a un seul espoir
jusque le kosovo deviennent vite
indépendant car si milosevic reste au
pouvoir
la boucherie va durer longtemps mois
leur premier repas entre amis fait
oublier les 17 jours passés au camp de
skopje une nouvelle vie commence
elle a le goût de l'exil sans doute pour
longtemps
s'agissant des colis adressés à la croix
rouge depuis les premiers appels lancés
il ya un peu plus de trois semaines nous
avons choisi marseille joue 72 tonnes
ont déjà été envoyés par avion vers
l'albanie un cargo est en partance dès
la fin de cette semaine avec une
nouvelle cargaison et le travail des
bénévoles et long car il faut
reconditionnés la moitié des colis
reportage yannick aroussi évinçant les
ombres
il y as peut-être de quoi s'y perdre
stocks d'aliments aux allures de
labyrinthe
certains jours l'aide humanitaire est
visiblement un perpétuel recommencement
c'est en train de vider des quarts temps
que déjà envoyé et nous répartissons
d'un différend portant
parce que ces colis n'ont pas les bonnes
dimensions ils sont systématiquement
ouvert et reconditionnés parfois il faut
également vérifier le contenu pour ne
pas tout mélanger des produits d'hygiène
effectivement des serviettes de toi le
poids de ce paquet avait alerté les
bénévoles coûtera sont des containers
pour chaque denrée pour les conserves du
ski alimentaire tout ce qui est vienne
savon etc
le but de l'opération est d'arriver à ce
type d'emballage facilement
transportable et suffisamment solides
pour être empilés dans une cale de
bateau depuis mercredi dernier plusieurs
centaines de bénévoles se relaient pour
venir à bout de cet énorme travail
vingt cinq jours nous avons reçu un peu
plus de 250 camions
c'est à dire environ 500 mille colis
telles que vous les voyez d'environ 7
collet unitaire dont il faut
conditionner au moins 50% 3500 tonnes d
aide humanitaire sont actuellement
stockés dans plusieurs entrepôts
marseillais quatre avions de la croix
rouge ont déjà transporté des colis vers
l'albanie
aujourd'hui quatre camions ont pris la
route pour tirana en fin de semaine un
cargo chargé de deux à trois mille
tonnes appareillera vers le port
albanais de durres s mais en attendant
chaque jour et chaque nuit des milliers
de colis sont acheminés vers marseille
la solidarité des français est exemple
voilà pour l'actualité au kosovo en
turquie sans surprise le parquet de la
cour de sûreté de l'état d'ankara vient
de rédiger un acte d'accusation contre
le chef rebelle kurde abdullah ocalan
acte d'accusation dans lequel la peine
de mort est réclamée en france ce fut
une journée politique pour la chance à
des partis de droite rpr udf ou
démocratie libérale plutôt active
cinq jours après la démission
fracassante de philippe seguin au rpr on
a cherché des raisons de croire encore à
l'union de l'opposition tandis que l'udf
il s'agissait surtout de se montrer unie
derrière françois bayrou commentaires
arnaud bouteyre écrire moscovitch d'un
côté le rpr au siège du mouvement
gaulliste se tenait un conseil politique
une réunion de crise dont ni les
sourires ni la décontraction affichée ne
peuvent masquer la gravité
nicolas sarkozy réclame une union de
l'opposition pour les européennes
l'udf fait la sourde oreille
au même moment les centristes organisait
un bureau politique pour évoquer le même
sujet très serein et très déterminés
pour rejoindre le rpr et démocratie
libérale idf maintient ces trois
conditions une défense et une
constitution européenne ainsi qu'un
président européen élu le rpr lui veut
conserver la tête de liste en cas
d'union chacun campe sur ses positions
alors sans trop y croire on refuse
d'admettre que tout est fini
aujourd'hui comme toujours d'ailleurs
comme depuis le début nous sommes
nombreux à penser qu'une liste d'union
répondra le mieux aux aspirations de
nos électrices de nos électeurs est ce
que les conditions seront réunies je
crois qu'il faut maintenant se décider
vite double langage à l'udps est
officiellement la porte de l'union reste
entrouverte mais une majorité de
dirigeants préfèrent maintenir une liste
séparée occupants sont une majorité
d'entre nous en tout cas que la
reconquête de l'opinion
la confiance des français passent par
une opposition plurielle c'est à dire
avant de sa côte à côte mais pas en file
indienne au pas cadencé dimanche
prochain l'udf donnera officiellement sa
réponse en réunissant son conseil
national
3000 délégués voteront pour dire s'ils
veulent oui ou non
l'union donc si je comprends bien gérard
l'union à droite c'est pas pour cette
fois ci côté les jeux effectivement
semblent faits les partisans d'une liste
udf autonome l'ont emporté haut la main
cet après midi avec trois arguments 1 le
coup est parti la campagne prend il n'y
a aucune raison de porter secours à un
rpr hégémonique qui est en train
d'exploser en vol 2 comme le démontre
tragiquement le kosovo d'urgence pour
l'udf et de porter haut les couleurs
d'une europe fédérale et non pas
édulcoré et puis 3 il faut jouer la
clarté la cohérence et jeter les bases
d'une nouvelle opposition plurielle et
mieux équilibré alors la porte encore
entrouverte à une liste commune sur des
convictions européennes et sous la
direction de l'udf donc sous ses
fourches caudines apparaît plutôt comme
une simple clause de style
hier je crois j'ai entendu si sarkozy
dire qu'il était zen est un peu
différent les moins envoyé beaucoup même
se disent ulcérés ce soir au rpr par
l'attitude à litière voir hargneux et
centristes on souligne que le communiqué
de l'udf ne prononce même pas le mot
d'union et ne fait pas référence à
jacques chirac en jouant les rebelles au
nom de l'europe soulignent les mêmes
françois daireaux risque de favoriser la
liste pasqua et de torpilles et
l'alternance le rpr ne se privera pas de
faire porter le mistigri de la division
à l'udf est plus remonté évoque même des
représailles possibles contre les
centristes lors des scrutins futurs dans
l'immédiat le rpr et d elles doivent
démocraties libérales doivent repartir
seul à la bataille derrière un nouveau
chef de file ce devrait être nicolas
sarkozy lui même et peut-être sans le
numéro deux alain madelin qui
envisagerait son tour de jeter l'épongé
merci gérard
stabilité de l'excédent commercial de la
france en février stabilité au niveau
d'un peu plus de 9 milliards de francs à
peu près comme au mois de janvier
dans la famille michelin le père
françois 73 ans va laisser sa place au
fils édouard 36 ans cette nomination
sera proposée lors de la prochaine
assemblée générale du 11 juin françois
michelin et le patron depuis 44 ans du
groupe de clermont ferrand il avait
lui-même succédé à son père à lille une
convention dette directe a été signé par
les représentants de l'état des
collectivités locales pour permettre la
construction de l'usiné toyota à onnaing
près de valenciennes construction de
cette usine avait été annoncée le 9
décembre 1997 le total des aides
directes et indirectes sera de près de
340 millions de francs en haute savoie à
chamonix une trentaine de membres des
familles des victimes de la catastrophe
du tunnel du mont blanc qui a fait 41
morts au moins le 24 mars dernier se
sont réunis s'agit pour ces familles de
mettre au point différentes actions
judiciaires
reportage virginie pichet thierry
monnier autour de leurs avocats str de
la moitié des familles de victimes se
sont aujourd'hui sous d une association
est née une manière de se sentir plus
fort pour assumer une longue marche
judiciaire et connaître un jour
peut-être toute la vérité sur le drame
qui les touchent l'ensemble des victimes
aujourd'hui la seule volonté quel on
sait la vérité savoir ce qu'il s'est
passé
rien d'autre je crois que toutes les
autres questions pour les victimes pour
l'instant
son accessoire le principal c'est la
vérité sur leur mort leur famille et
ensuite la vérité sur les circonstances
de l'accident de cette première
rencontre qui a duré près de trois
heures les familles françaises ou
italiennes sont ressortis avec la ferme
intention de se constituer partie civile
en se regroupant elles veulent aussi
répondre au mépris avec lequel elles ont
le sentiment d'avoir été traité
jusqu'ici notamment par la société
gestionnaire du tunnel ya un véritable
sentiment de révolte car pour certaines
de ces familles qui ont perdu plusieurs
des membres de leur famille ils ont la
conviction profonde la certitude ancrée
en font au fond d'elle-même que que cela
n'est pas normal que ce drame aurait pu
être évité que une fois de plus on a
sacrifié des vies humaines
sur l'autel de la rentabilité et ça
c'est pas acceptable la tmb a débloqué
la semaine dernière six cent cinquante
mille francs à destination des familles
ce matin les premiers véhicules calcinés
ont été sortis du tunnel carcasses qui
ne remplaceront jamais les corps que les
familles attendent les légistes de
grenoble continue leur minutieux travail
d'identification pour l'instant huit
seulement des quarante et une victimes
ont été identifiées
les compétitions de football suspendu
après de multiples agressions et
violences dans les stades dans le
département de seine-saint-denis doivent
reprendre dès la fin de cette semaine
une majorité de présidents de clubs de
la région seine-saint-denis s'est
prononcé en faveur de cette reprise
compte tenu d'un dispositif renforcé de
prévention policière mais les débats
s'étaient plutôt passionné voyez le
reportage d'olivier caroff et guillon
fautrat carton vert pour une reprise
immédiate des matches
carton rouge pour maintenir
l'interdiction des compétitions hier
soir le petit monde du football en seine
saint denis a rendu son arbitrage
les verts ont gagné les autres ont
parfois bureau
cet entraîneur s'en prend directement au
représentant du ministère de la jeunesse
et des sports des représentants qui à la
tribune sont venus annoncer un
renforcement de la sécurité adaptées
pense-t-il au risque de violences
les matches à risque nous était fort peu
signalé pour ne pas dire pas du tout
c'est de faire le point chaque semaine
avec le président bourdin sur l'ensemble
des matchs qui vont être joués dans le
département de déterminer avec lui les
matches à risques de façon à vous
assurer sur ces matches à risques la
présence policière plus de policiers
dans les stades et 2000 emplois jeunes
dans les clubs
un plan que certains jugent inadaptée
aux trente mille jeunes joueurs du
département
ce soit on entendu parler
essentiellement de forces de polices de
force l'europe mais nous éducateurs
notre souhait c'est qu'il y ait plus
justement
forces de police dans les stades et
canton ça arrive on ça arrive est
atteint c'est qu'on aura gagné tous
ensemble effectivement nous faut les
éducateurs et des gens qui portent le
nom d'éducateur on vous l'a dit déjà la
dernière fois arrêté d'appeler des
éducateurs des gens qui ne sont pas
éducateur
après deux semaines d'interruption les
mains tu reprendront dès samedi
l'an dernier plus de 700 incidents
s'étaient produits dans les tribunes ou
sur les terrains cinéma la fille d'un
soldat ne pleure jamais c'est le joli
titre du dernier film proposé par james
ivory cinéaste américain qui adapte
ainsi à l'écran le roman
autobiographique de la fille de james
jones
l'auteur de tant qu'il y aura des hommes
l'action du film se situe dans les
années 60 et james ivory auteur
notamment des vestiges du jour ou encore
de chambre avec vues raconte avec
infiniment de délicatesse une histoire
toute simple présentation nicole cornu
l'endroit avec frédéric de la rue c'est
la chronique d'une famille chaleureuse
fin des années 60 à paris un couple
d'américains willis est un écrivain
célèbre sa femme vit très librement en
bois joue au poker et les relations
entre le père et la fille sont très
affectueuse
devenu adulte c'est elle qui nous
racontent toute la gamme des sentiments
avec l'adoption d'un petit frère j'étais
surtout intéressé par les relations très
intimes entre les membres de cette
famille c'est ce que je voulais montrer
ce n'est pas vraiment la confrontation
entre deux types de société la française
l'américaine mais plutôt comment une
famille s'étant adaptée à paris pour un
certain temps doit repartir dans son
pays tels des oiseaux migrateurs et le
retour un peu forcé aux états unis est
plus difficile à vivre pour les deux
jeunes considérés comme étant des
françaises cherchent un james ivory a
toujours eu l'art d'obtenir le meilleur
de ses acteurs dans ce film en
particulier quand ils me dirigeais c'est
comme je suis un morceau de terre
d'accord je suis un morceau de terre et
puis dans un commerce du sel je demande
alors tu veux que je suis là quelle
forme
parce que je suis sept morceaux de terre
puis 10 alors team serbe
alors c'est comme ça je sais même pas
que je suis en train de diriger c'est
comme quand un enfant est dans dans
l'école et ils s'amusent ils savent même
pas qu'ils sont en train d'apprendre
comment
à défaut de scénario très fort tout se
joue sur des émotions subtiles que l'on
partage avec des acteurs pleins de
charme et de sensibilité avant de
refermer ce journal je vous rappelle
deux informations que nous avons
développés concernant l'actualité
présents au kosovo les serbes font
monter la pression monte negro il ferme
la frontière entre ce pays d'à croatie
il ya eu des échanges de tirs entre
serbes et albanais à la frontière l'otan
a renforcé son dispositif militaire et
en macédoine les autorités cherchent
organisé un recensement précis des
milliers de réfugiés kosovars en
politique qu'en france a droit plus df
n'ira pas au rassemblement aux élections
européennes en compagnie du rpr derrière
françois bayrou les élus centristes
maintiennent leur autonomie dans
quelques secondes vous retrouverez
isabelle martinet pour la météo puis le
magazine place de la république ce sera
à 23h20 à 1h10 le journal de l'ami
suisse sera suivie pas du cercle de
philippe lefebvre n'a de la nuit
présentée par laurence ostolaza demain
7h50 françoise david recevra claude
goasguen le député udf puis à 13h vous
retrouverez rachid arhab à demain 20
heures vont ce soir
merci
je